So, software is what controls
our computer systems.
We get things done by running
software that we write, or
somebody else has written for us.
And, we're going to talk about
exactly what are those bugs
that actually turn into vulnerabilities.
We're also going to talk
about how exactly those bugs,
or others get exploited.
So the vulnerabilities that we're
going to talk about come because of
memory overflow.
Keep in mind memory overflow means
that the amount of memory we have for
a certain data type is not sufficient so
the data type runs over
the allocated space.
And an attacker is actually able
to exploit a program by inserting
new code sometimes in
certain part of memory.
And also then directing or transferring
control of that code to the instructions
that the attacker has introduced in
this memory that we're talking about.
Stack is the area where
we allocate space for
dynamically created data items or
variables.
So the most common example
of when you use a stack
is when you make a function call or
a procedure call.
When we do that,
the variables that we need
to execute the function code
get allocated on the stack.
So, as you make function calls,
or procedure calls,
for each call we create what we
call a stack frame on the stack.
This stack frame essentially you can
think about, gives us the scratch pad or
the memory that we going to need for
the execution of this function.
It's created when
the function is called and
it is discarded when the function
finishes and returns.
So what exactly is stored
in the stack frame?
Part of this we're going to
allocate space for local variables
that are going to be used by
the code defined by the function.
Also parameters that
we're going to pass.
This is data that we're
going to pass to the function.
Those arguments or parameters are going
to be stored in the stack frame.
And we also store control information.
So remember when you call the function,
you are doing control transfer,
from where you were,
to where this function code is.
When you get done with the function,
you have to return to the point
from where you had made the call.
And the vulnerability that
we're going to explore today,
which is buffer overflow,
stack buffer overflow
is actually going to manipulate
the memory that is in this frame.
Before we actually get into the details,
I should mention the software
vulnerabilities that we have.
An attacker is allowed to call
a program that you run on your system.
The program may have
an interface that allows
legitimate users to make calls to it.
And when they make those calls they
are actually going to pass some data, so
the entry point here is
actually a legitimate call
that could be made by
users of this program.
They pass certain kind of data and
the attacker is going to pass
data that is not what we expect.
As a result it's going to lead to this
overflow that we're talking about.